Shure: 1399
Shure: 然后去掉那什么的话
Shure: And then if we remove that...
Shure: get up
Shure: Get up
Shure: 起床啦
Shure: Time to get up
Shure: 路亚起床啦
Shure: Luya, wake up
Shure: 吧啦吧
Shure: Blah blah
Jack: 他怎么证明过
Jack: How did he prove it?
Nicous: 他会让你自己去见
Nicous: He'll let you see for yourself
Nicous: 外面晒一下回来给他
Nicous: Go outside and get some sun, then show him
Jack: 真的吗啊
Jack: Really?
Nicous: 我同学去换平板去了
Nicous: My classmate went to exchange his tablet
Nicous: 他那个平板
Nicous: His tablet...
Nicous: 他他他
Nicous: He, he, he...
Nicous: 那个店员说我这个没办法鉴定你损坏
Nicous: The clerk said they couldn't determine the damage
Nicous: 你赶快出去偷偷晒完款
Nicous: So quickly go outside and sun it
Jack: 哈哈哈操
Jack: Hahaha, damn
Jack: 你这搞得我心动了
Jack: Now I'm tempted
Jack: 这我用一年刚把屏摔了
Jack: I've been using it for a year and just broke the screen
Nicous: 不是我第一次磕他磕的
Nicous: It wasn't the first time I bumped it
Shure: 我没喝
Shure: I didn't drink
Nicous: 你又没喝
Nicous: You didn't drink
Shure: 我没喝
Shure: I didn't drink
Shure: 你找不到
Shure: You can't find it
Nicous: 那感觉平时其实用不到Pro啊
Nicous: It feels like I don't really need the Pro version
Nicous: 我我我也
Nicous: I, I, I...
Jack: 那CPU都不带转的
Jack: The CPU doesn't even spin
Nicous: 我现在也后悔了
Nicous: Now I regret it too
Nicous: 因为说实话该发烫的时候他还是烫
Nicous: Honestly, it still gets hot when it should
Jack: 他不是会烫吗
Jack: Doesn't it get hot?
Nicous: 就是
Nicous: Exactly
Nicous: Chrome开多了
Nicous: When you open too many Chrome tabs
Jack: 哈哈哈Chrome开多了会烫
Jack: Hahaha, opening too many Chrome tabs heats it up
Jack: 真的吗哦
Jack: Really?
Nicous: 我知道怎么会烫了
Nicous: I know why it heats up
Nicous: 中文输入法卡的时候
Nicous: When the Chinese input method lags
Jack: 我都没有中文输入法
Jack: I don't even use the Chinese input method
Jack: 我用他默认
Jack: I use the default one
Shure: 他那默认有一个bug
Shure: The default one has a bug
Shure: 就是会让你整个电脑卡死
Shure: It can freeze your entire computer
Shure: 就是过一段时就是
Shure: After a while, it just...
Shure: 比如说你可能十多天不关电脑
Shure: For example, you might not turn off your computer for more than ten days.
Nicous: 还是他给我讲太傻逼了
Nicous: Or he explained it to me in such a dumb way.
Jack: 怎么10多天
Jack: How is it more than ten days?
Jack: 我电脑没有输过中文就会卡死
Jack: My computer freezes if I input Chinese for too long.
Shure: 不是不是不是
Shure: No, no, no.
Nicous: 10多天他就会卡死
Nicous: It freezes after more than ten days.
Jack: 我已经用了有10多天了
Jack: I've been using it for more than ten days.
Choiszt: 是所有都有这个问题
Choiszt: Does everyone have this problem?
Shure: 所有只要你是有中文中文输入法的
Shure: Everyone who uses a Chinese input method does.
Shure: 就就会
Shure: It just...
Shure: 就全是那个
Shure: It's just all that.
Choiszt: 自己新装的中文输入法
Choiszt: Installed your own Chinese input method?
Shure: 不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Choiszt: 卧槽十多天早没电了
Choiszt: Damn, it would've run out of power long ago.
Choiszt: 早没电一次了
Choiszt: It would've run out of power once already.
Choiszt: 冰竹的MacBook Pro啊
Choiszt: Bingzhu's MacBook Pro, huh?
Choiszt: 不是你自己电脑
Choiszt: Not your own computer?
Shure: 为什么还有自己
Shure: Why would it be your own?
Choiszt: 你自己电脑的电量显示
Choiszt: The battery indicator on your own computer.
Nicous: 那是因为我装了很多很多插件
Nicous: That's because I installed a lot of plugins.
Nicous: 很多好好用的插件
Nicous: A lot of really useful plugins.
Nicous: 比如说你们有没有遇到这种问题
Nicous: For example, have you guys encountered this problem?
Nicous: 就是菜单栏太多了
Nicous: That the menu bar is too crowded?
Nicous: 嗯然后就有个插件门
Nicous: So, there's a plugin...
Nicous: 哎反正
Nicous: Anyway...
Nicous: 啊就是要不然你就显示不出来了
Nicous: Otherwise, it just won't display.
Jack: 没有我一般不会开
Jack: No, I usually don't turn it on.
Jack: 我感我感觉我
Jack: I feel like I...
Jack: 我用Mac的动机非常的纯粹
Jack: My motivation for using a Mac is very pure.
Nicous: 就是你们那个你
Nicous: You guys, you...
Nicous: 你以前没有这个调的时候他们都是显
Nicous: Before you had this adjustment, they all displayed...
Nicous: 就是这个
Nicous: Like this...
Nicous: 刘海屏的时候他都显在这吗
Nicous: When you had a notch screen, it all displayed here, right?
Nicous: 啊这就全部显示一排吗
Nicous: Yeah, it showed everything in a row here.
Nicous: 现在刘海屏在这
Nicous: Now with the notch screen...
Nicous: 他有时候就显示不出来了
Nicous: Sometimes it just won't display.
Jack: 这么逆天啊
Jack: That's so crazy!
Nicous: 很逆天
Nicous: Really crazy.
Nicous: 然后就得下个插件让他往下面显示
Nicous: So you need a plugin to make it show below.
Choiszt: 不是啥意思
Choiszt: Wait, what do you mean?
Nicous: 就是你看我现在的那个上面的
Nicous: You see, like the one I have up here.
Shure: 你看我这个还白看不到本地
Shure: Look at mine, it's still white, can't see the local one.
Shure: 为什么为什么
Shure: Why, why?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Nicous: 那你你不装插件他就显示不了啊
Nicous: If you don't install the plugin, it won't show up.
Nicous: 你找不到他啊
Nicous: You can't find it.
Jack: 他又被刘海屏挡住了
Jack: It's blocked by the notch again.
Choiszt: 在这看
Choiszt: Look here.
Jack: 妈你有病啊
Jack: Are you nuts?
Jack: 再强制退出
Jack: Force quit again.
Jack: 你得你得
Jack: You need to
Jack: 抽线
Jack: unplug it.
Nicous: 你就你就你就是不卡了似的
Nicous: You act like it never lags.
Nicous: 哈哈直接推了
Nicous: Haha, just quit directly.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈不是你好
Choiszt: Hahaha, not you.
Choiszt: 知道你后台都有什么运行
Choiszt: Do you know what's running in your background?
Jack: 但我发现用Mac这Mac真快
Jack: But I found using Mac, this Mac is really fast.
Choiszt: 你是最近新买的
Choiszt: Did you buy it recently?
Jack: 对我去上海那个静安店买
Jack: Yeah, I bought it at the Jing'an store in Shanghai.
Jack: 我觉我觉得Mac最爽的地方就是
Jack: I think the best thing about Mac is
Jack: 就是我之前连傻屌腾讯服务器啊
Jack: before, when I connected to the dumb Tencent server,
Jack: 它那个服务器
Jack: that server,
Jack: 就是它是要单独下一个应用啊
Jack: you had to download a separate app to connect.
Jack: 然后连接
Jack: Then connect.
Jack: 然后你只要断开之后你就要reconnect
Jack: And once you disconnect, you have to reconnect.
Jack: 然后它那个要输一个你的PIN
Jack: Then you have to enter your PIN.
Jack: 加一个定时的TOKEN
Jack: Plus a timed TOKEN.
Jack: 然后就每次连他时候就要就要先输pink
Jack: Every time you connect, you have to enter the PIN first.
Jack: 然后再打开手机
Jack: Then open your phone.
Jack: 然后还有还有解码
Jack: And then decode.
Jack: 然后看那个风格
Jack: Then look at the style.
Jack: 然后我的Windows笔就只要合上
Jack: And my Windows laptop, just close it.
Jack: 他就打开
Jack: When it opens,
Jack: 就要重连但
Jack: you have to reconnect.
Jack: 是Mac他
Jack: But with Mac,
Jack: 我合上打开只要他中间网就断了
Jack: I just close and open it, and the connection breaks.
Shure: 我可以直接把这个整个的
Shure: I can just copy the whole
Shure: 那个文件夹给拷贝
Shure: folder over, right?
Shure: 下来吗
Shure: Can I?
Jack: 呃你可以把那个什么sadpackage里面
Jack: Uh, you can take the sad package inside.
Choiszt: 装了双系统吗
Choiszt: Did you install a dual system?
Shure: 不不是就是比如说我这个
Shure: No, no, it's just that, for example, this one
Shure: 这是本来我所有的装好的环境
Shure: This is all my pre-installed environment
Shure: 就是根据这个路径找到的这个
Shure: It's found based on this path
Shure: 叭叭叭叭就这么多东西
Shure: Bam bam bam, just so many things
Shure: 然后可以直接把他copy过来
Shure: Then you can just copy it over
Shure: 然后用它来打开
Shure: And then use it to open
Shure: 一个什么吗
Shure: Something, right?
Jack: 坏了这我就不知道了
Jack: Well, I don't know about that
Jack: 但但但你要
Jack: But, but, but you need to
Jack: 你要装什么
Jack: What do you need to install
Jack: 就是环境依赖很强的东西吗
Jack: Is it something with strong environmental dependencies?
Shure: 我就是忘了他要装什么了
Shure: I just forgot what he needed to install
Jack: 哈哈那你不是
Jack: Haha, then aren't you
Jack: 那你直接康大利斯他一下呗
Jack: Then you just give it a Cornellis
Shure: 要不就我康纳利死了之后然后他
Shure: Either I Cornellis it and then he
Shure: 他利死完那个之后
Shure: After he finishes the Lis
Shure: 他不知道为什么装不回去啊
Shure: He doesn't know why it won't install back
Jack: 不
Jack: No
Jack: 你利死了之后你就看哪些包是需要的
Jack: After you Lis it, you check which packages are needed
Shure: 哎
Shure: Eh
Jack: 但康纳好像有一个备份的策略啊
Jack: But Cornell seems to have a backup strategy
Shure: 对啊他Baika然后Baika的安联
Shure: Yeah, he Baika and then Baika's Allianz
Shure: 康纳cloud了
Shure: Cornell clouded it
Jack: 你为什么要在本地装
Jack: Why do you need to install locally
Shure: 什么
Shure: What
Jack: 你为什么要在本地装account
Jack: Why do you need to install account locally?
Shure: 你说为什么在本地装account
Shure: You mean why install account locally?
Shure: 这个就
Shure: It's just
Shure: 反正就是我为了方便
Shure: Anyway, for convenience
Shure: 把它直接给弄出来
Shure: I just got it out directly
Shure: 然后我给他备份到这个cloud里面了
Shure: Then I backed it up to the cloud
Shure: 然后备份到cloud之后然后我
Shure: Then after backing it up to the cloud
Shure: 我从这个服务器
Shure: I imported it from this server
Shure: 这个啊然后再再再再给他import
Shure: This, and then, then, then imported it back
Shure: 他回来他就import不回来
Shure: When he comes back, he can't import it back
Jack: 报啥错呀
Jack: What error does it report?
Jack: 为什么感觉这么奇怪
Jack: Why does it feel so strange
Jack: 我觉得艾文康还是比较智能的
Jack: I think Ivan Korn is quite smart
Shure: 我也觉得他很智能
Shure: I also think he's very smart
Jake:还没搞定
Jake: Still not done.
Jack: import不进来
Jack: Can't import it.
Jack: 这不会的
Jack: This won't work.
Jake:用命令行啊
Jake: Use the command line.
Jake:别用这玩意
Jake: Don't use this tool.
Jack: 命令行命令行
Jack: Command line, command line.
Jack: 他都已经正常
Jack: It's already normal.
Jack: 把requirements导出来他在他requirements带
Jack: Export the requirements, it's in the requirements.
Jack: 的是就是他带着本地路径
Jack: It includes the local path.
Jack: 那么g
Jack: So g-
Jack: 我没有见过requirements带本地路径哦
Jack: I've never seen requirements include a local path.
Choiszt: 就你在f那个
Choiszt: Just in the f- that-
Shure: 为什么会这样啊
Shure: Why is it like this?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jack: 你你你点开requirements看一下啊
Jack: You, you, you open the requirements and take a look.
Jack: 这个这个这个
Jack: This, this, this.
Jack: 带路径我第一次见
Jack: This is the first time I've seen a path included.
Jack: 对啊
Jack: Yeah.
Jake:康大印刷文帝是吧
Jake: Kangda printed Wen Di, right?
Shure: 等一下
Shure: Wait a minute.
Jake:康大list
Jake: Kangda list.
Jake:康大利斯出来
Jake: Kangda list it out.
Jake:这么傻逼玩意
Jake: Such a stupid thing.
Nicous: 康大出来的其实不傻逼
Nicous: Kangda's stuff isn't actually stupid.
Nicous: 但是p不出来的很傻逼
Nicous: But what's not coming out is really stupid.
Choiszt: 卧槽你这么多环境
Choiszt: Wow, you have so many environments.
Jack: 怎么会这样
Jack: How could this happen?
Shure: 没懂啥玩意不会
Shure: I don't get it, why won't it work?
Choiszt: 啥呀我看看
Choiszt: What? Let me see.
Nicous: 不会画一下
Nicous: Won't you draw it out?
Choiszt: 配环境之神
Choiszt: Environment setup god.
Choiszt: 咋了
Choiszt: What's up?
Shure: 你是神吗
Shure: Are you a god?
Shure: 你真神吗
Shure: Are you really a god?
Shure: 真神
Shure: A real god.
Shure: 就是我在这那个掰卡子好了一个
Shure: I just fixed one of those things here.
Shure: 然后我再import回去
Shure: Then I imported it back.
Shure: 他就
Shure: It just-
Shure: 就是备份了一个啊
Shure: It just backed up one.
Shure: 然后直接点的这个import就
Shure: Then directly clicked this import and...
Shure: 对他正在装
Shure: Yeah, he's installing it.
Shure: 然后他装一会他就会报错开始
Shure: Then after he installs it for a while, it will start giving errors.
Choiszt: 这是你环境名字吗
Choiszt: Is this the name of your environment?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jack: 我来学习一下
Jack: Let me learn this.
Jack: 以防哪天我需要copy我的炕
Jack: Just in case I need to copy my setup someday.
Nicous: 我也要学习
Nicous: I need to learn too.
Choiszt: 不是你为啥不能直接重装呢
Choiszt: Why can't you just reinstall it directly?
Shure: 我忘了我就是忘了
Shure: I forgot, I just forgot.
Shure: 他已经我
Shure: He's already...
Jack: 我问了他他肯定也问了
Jack: I asked him, he definitely asked too.
Choiszt: 就是就是
Choiszt: Exactly, exactly.
Shure: 你忘了你以前装过啥
Shure: You forgot what you installed before?
Shure: 我以前装过啥
Shure: What did I install before?
Shure: 我全忘了
Shure: I forgot everything.
Choiszt: 我觉得你还不如现在先装
Choiszt: I think you might as well start installing now.
Choiszt: 然后看他就缺什么库
Choiszt: And then see what libraries are missing.
Jack: 你是要
Jack: Are you...
Jack: 你是只要跑一段cold是吗
Jack: Do you just need to run a segment of code?
Shure: 我不是我就是
Shure: No, it's just that...
Shure: 哎呀怎么说呢
Shure: How should I put this...
Shure: 就是
Shure: It's just that...
Shure: 反正这个东西完全不是我自己写的
Shure: Anyway, this thing wasn't written by me.
Shure: 我当时就
Shure: At that time, I...
Jack: 那你就缺啥你就造啥呗
Jack: Then just build whatever you need.
Shure: 行那我就
Shure: Alright, then I'll...
Nicous: 你为什么天天给我威业啊
Nicous: Why do you always send me messages?
Jack: 不会有那么强的环境感吧
Jack: It shouldn't feel that intense.
Choiszt: 这不是想让你抽吗
Choiszt: Isn't it just to make you smoke?
Nicous: 你他妈的
Nicous: Damn it.
Nicous: 你他妈国家烟草的吧
Nicous: Are you with the national tobacco company or something?
Jack: 我用过所有库里面
Jack: Among all the libraries I've used...
Jack: 我觉得除了穿summer那种傻逼库
Jack: I think except for that stupid summer library...
Jack: 前后不兼容之外
Jack: Which is incompatible...
Jack: 剩下库对版本没有任何依赖
Jack: The rest of the libraries don't depend on any version.
Choiszt: 卧槽确实
Choiszt: That's true.
Jack: 穿summer那个库真的很傻逼
Jack: That summer library is really stupid.
Choiszt: 我觉得那个OPI那个库有点傻逼
Choiszt: I think that OPI library is a bit stupid.
Jack: 我当时我当时写这个
Jack: When I wrote this...
Jack: 他不是那个他
Jack: It wasn't that...
Jack: 他那些蓝光荣耀都用Flash tension two嘛
Jack: He uses Flash tension two for all those Blue Glory things.
Jack: 啊然后他两个版本之间
Jack: Ah, then between the two versions
Jack: Flash tension two就enable
Jack: Flash tension two is enabled.
Jack: Flash tension two那个q word不一样
Jack: The q word for Flash tension two is different.
Jack: 然后
Jack: And then
Jack: 然后就上一版本扣了copy过来
Jack: So in the previous version, it copied over.
Jack: 就Flash tension two根本就没开
Jack: Flash tension two wasn't even enabled.
Jack: 而且因为它是传在那个coalx里面啊
Jack: And because it was transmitted in the coalx,
Jack: 所以它不会报错
Jack: it didn't report an error.
Jack: 它会正常跑上去
Jack: It ran normally.
Jack: 但是速度慢两倍
Jack: But it was twice as slow.
Choiszt: 就是你根本没启动flag tension two
Choiszt: So you didn't enable Flash tension two at all.
Jack: 对但它不报错
Jack: Yes, but it didn't report an error.
Jack: 你你你跑一个你跑一个
Jack: You, you, you run one, you run one.
Jack: 看缺啥就行
Jack: See what's missing.
Jack: 缺啥装啥
Jack: Install whatever is missing.
Jack: 这个这个是一定是最最快的
Jack: This is definitely the fastest way.
Nicous: 就是给你重温一下
Nicous: Just to refresh your memory.
Nicous: 巩固一下
Nicous: Reinforce it.
Nicous: 然后毕设
Nicous: And then for the final project.
Nicous: 然后答辩提问你
Nicous: Then during the defense, they'll ask you questions.
Nicous: 你不就能说了
Nicous: You'll be able to answer.
Choiszt: 谁他妈毕设问你装啥
Choiszt: Who the hell asks what you installed for the final project?
Shure: 呵呵呵我瞎他妈说
Shure: Haha, I'm just talking nonsense.
Shure: 他不也也也不知道我装的什么
Shure: They don't really know what I installed anyway.
Shure: 环境
Shure: Environment.
Nicous: 你要为你自己负责
Nicous: You have to be responsible for yourself.
Nicous: 你这以后别人
Nicous: In the future, others...
Shure: 你滚
Shure: Get lost.
Shure: 我以后我就他妈都不干这行
Shure: In the future, I won't even be in this field.
Nicous: 我以后就举报你
Nicous: In the future, I'll report you.
Nicous: 毕设
Nicous: Final project.
Shure: 你举报你
Shure: You report me,
Shure: 我举报你的
Shure: I'll report you.
Shure: 你经查吗
Shure: You think they'll check?
Nicous: 我全是自编的
Nicous: I made it all up.
Nicous: 你举报吧
Nicous: Go ahead and report.
Nicous: 一举报一个准
Nicous: Every report will be accurate.
Jack: 举报毕设没用的
Jack: Reporting final projects is useless.
Jack: 你必须要被选在那个系统里面举报才有用
Jack: You have to be selected in that system for the report to be effective.
Jack: 就他有一个什么什么毕业选
Jack: He has some kind of graduation choice.
Choiszt: 卧槽他那个写了就是什么伪造数据
Choiszt: Damn, he wrote something about faking data.
Nicous: 没关系我的数据怎么是伪造的呢
Nicous: No worries, how could my data be fake?
Nicous: 那只能说GPT太不稳定了
Nicous: That just means GPT is too unstable.
Jack: 0.2 哈哈哈
Jack: 0.2, hahaha.
Jack: 0.2
Jack: 0.2.
Nicous: 就是的没办法我就喜欢随机
Nicous: Yeah, I just love randomness.
Jack: 他们这0.2套路
Jack: Their 0.2 trick.
Jack: p等于0.5
Jack: p equals 0.5.
Choiszt: 哈哈哈这说的有道理
Choiszt: Hahaha, that makes sense.
Nicous: 不然我怎么改随机的
Nicous: Otherwise, how would I change the randomness?
Choiszt: 不是你out都在这上跑吗
Choiszt: Isn't your output running on this?
Jack: 这电脑这能跑
Jack: This computer can handle it.
Nicous: 跑的inference是吧
Nicous: Running inference, right?
Nicous: 啊没有跑哎
Nicous: Oh, not running.
Choiszt: 这个怎么看显存
Choiszt: How do you check the VRAM?
Choiszt: 就是就是
Choiszt: Exactly, exactly.
Nicous: 怎么会有人看Mac的显存
Nicous: Who checks the VRAM on a Mac?
Nicous: 我真不能理解
Nicous: I really can't understand.
Shure: 它没有显存
Shure: It doesn't have VRAM.
Choiszt: Mac不是CPU GPU一块吗
Choiszt: Isn't Mac's CPU and GPU combined?
Shure: 对它算一个
Shure: Yeah, it's counted as one.
Shure: 你把那活动监视器打开就能看了
Shure: Just open the Activity Monitor and you can see it.
Choiszt: 嗯
Choiszt: Hmm.
Shure: 不是他们俩不分你知道吧
Shure: They don't separate, you know that, right?
Nicous: 十六g对啊
Nicous: Sixteen gigs, right.
Nicous: 现在是不是18起步
Nicous: Now it's starting at 18, right?
Jake:搞定了吗
Jake: Done yet?
Choiszt: 十六g能跑个啥呢
Choiszt: What can sixteen gigs run?
Shure: 没没搞定
Shure: No, not done.
Shure: 但是可以可以进行下一个活动
Shure: But we can move to the next activity.
Katrina: 要让他们带一个自己的二手物品啊
Katrina: They should bring their own used items, right?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Oh, right.
Nicous: 十六g能跑啥呢
Nicous: What can sixteen gigs run?
Nicous: 别造我的
Nicous: Don't fake my stuff.
其他人：你去糟你的信任就行了
Others: You just need to trust yours.
Jack: 我十六g
Jack: My sixteen gigs.
Jack: 十六g已经可以跑千万1.8b哈哈
Jack: Sixteen gigs can already run a million 1.8b, haha.
Jack: 16G的显示
Jack: Sixteen gigs display.
Jake:不够吧感觉够
Jake: Doesn't feel enough, does it?
Choiszt: 还有账号吗
Choiszt: Do you have any more accounts?
Jake:还是没装上
Jake: Still couldn't install it.
Jack: 你你缺什么呢
Jack: What are you missing?
Jake:你知道看这个数据集的人一般都会装
Jake: You know, people who look at this dataset usually install it.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 你哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: You, hahaha.
Shure: 卧槽太侮辱我了吧
Shure: Damn, that's an insult to me.
Shure: 不是哈哈
Shure: No, haha.
Jack: 哎能access啊
Jack: Hey, can you access it?
Jack: 这个数据一般都是装好才能access
Jack: Usually, you need to install it to access this data.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 太侮辱我了
Shure: So insulting.
Jack: 看一下你这感觉不缺啥呀
Jack: Doesn't seem like you're missing anything.
Shure: 肯定缺
Shure: Definitely missing something.
Jack: 那你那你随便跑一个
Jack: Then just run one.
Jack: 你要跑哪个
Jack: Which one are you running?
Jack: 你跑一个
Jack: You run one.
Jack: 中单跑一个
Jack: Run a mid one.